[Music]
hello and a very warm welcome indeed to
quadriga and it's been a tempestuous
week in german politics with the refugee
crisis once again
topping the agenda angela merkel faced
an open rebellion
led by this man her interior minister
jose hoffer
he forced the chancellor to shift
further away than ever before from her
open door refugee policy
and accept the creation of proposed
screening camps or transit centers for
asylum seekers
along germany's southern border the
dispute took merkel's government to the
brink of collapse and big questions are
now being asked
about how her coalition can possibly
work together in the weeks
and months to come so our question here
on quadriga this week is german
stability a thing of the past
question mark and to discuss that
question i'm joined here in the studio
by three astute observers of german
politics
beginning with matthew karnichnik chief
european correspondent at politico
and matthew argues that german politics
is becoming less boring not less stable
there's a good name he says for the type
of confrontation we've seen in berlin
over the past few weeks
and that name is democracy also with us
is derek scalley of the irish times who
says germany's stability obsession
has done more harm than good to
democracy in the merkel era
more flexibility will bring fresh air
fresh thinking
and fresh partners into the political
game
interesting stuff and a very warm
welcome too to nina harza the head of
dw's domestic politics department
nina believes the anti-immigrant
alternative for germany party
is the only winner in the current
government crisis it's bad news for
chancellor merkel
and bad news for the eu okay derek let
me begin with you we've seen this clash
of titans here in german politics these
last couple of weeks
what's it all been about and where does
it leave us it's all been about power
it's about been positioning and it's
been about impatience
angela merkel has been in power for
almost 13 years and there's a backlog of
young men who some seem to think that
their best place to replace her and uh
we have young one young man well i'm not
saying 53 down in bavaria marcus
he has got an election coming up in
october and he thinks unless he gives
anger america a whack the voters are
going to give him a whack in october
on the migration quest for three years
they've been sort of the conservatives
down in bavaria if you've been cow
towing to merkel and now they need to go
back
even though the migration crisis really
isn't a crisis anymore but they feel
they need to set a sign so they decided
so you say the migration crisis isn't a
crisis everybody outside germany would
would
would say yes it is it's the big crisis
in terms of numbers if you uh if you are
worried about five or 10 or 20 people
coming across and seeking silent
bavarian every day within is a crisis
and around europe
is a crisis but compared to where we
were in 2015 in terms of pure numbers
it isn't a crisis the notion that it
just sort of two weeks ago suddenly
became a crisis again
i think that was an artificial crisis so
what we saw was the csu
the summer holidays are coming up this
is the last chance to really get
people's attention before
the autumn and uh give them the sense
that we are tough we have stood up to
miracles so
i think what we saw was just politics um
that it has that there is an unresolved
migration crisis is true
and that has gotten the rest of europe
talking about it perhaps it was an
unintended positive outcome the csu will
claim this is what we intended all along
it's not about power it's about
we are we're just we're worried about
europe i i doubt that very much
i wonder what nina has to say about all
that derek
unseemly and damaging for the whole
political culture say the critics is
that
you know derek's downplaying it some are
saying this is a real challenge to
germany's political culture the way this
battle has been fought out
yeah and the interesting thing is that
um like
we said earlier i'm convinced that the
only winner in this
um unseemly debate in this public row
that was
unnecessarily harsh um is the
anti-immigrant afd and the interesting
thing is that they didn't have to do
anything
they've entered they entered parliament
in uh last year's federal elections with
some 12 percent or so of supporting the
strongest opposition
parliament exactly and a vocal force in
parliament and of course you can say
that democracy is livelier since they've
entered parliament
and debates are livelier in the
bundestag but
since this row their support according
to latest polls
has risen to some 16 percent
and this is something where you have to
say will they stop at migration or will
they not choose different topics in the
future
now that they've got the conservatives
to essentially
uh take on and adopt their topics will
they stop that or will they will they go
and uh talk about the euro talk about
um housing which is a big problem in
some big germans
just give our viewers a sense of the
language that the afd has been using
this past week or so they've been you
they've been talking about hunting yes
they said that at the very night they
enter parliament for the first time
we're going to hunt
the government and hunt angela merkel
and hunt angela merkel
and then um at the height of this
current
government crisis they stood there and
said look we're hunting
yeah it sends a shiver down your spine a
little bit yeah it does yeah matthew
the uh the clash between seahorse and
merkel has been described as a faster
charade laughable self-delusion what do
you make of it all
well i think it was probably inevitable
given where the csu has been
on this issue all along i mean if you go
back to 2015 and remember
this is uh something that started when
merkel failed to
inform seihoufer that she was going to
let in these refugees who had been
trapped
in uh in hungary and that were many of
them on their way on foot uh via austria
to germany
and uh did she fail to inform him he's
often said that
the horseshoe took the phone off the
hook and went to bed early
well whoever knows the details you would
have to assume that the chancellor of
germany would have ways to
uh get into touch with uh her coalition
partner
if she needed to and you know you get
the sense that this is very
personal this dispute between the two of
them and i think that's something that
came out this week as well with some of
the comments that sejolfo made
such as i'm not going to let you know
this this woman
uh fire me i made her chancellor and
this this kind of thing
which would seem slightly gratuitous
because that was said just before they
they reached this this compromise so you
can really feel i think also
when you see the two of them together
that there's no love lost uh
between the two of them they've been
colleagues in various positions for the
past 30 years
so i i i think that at some point this
was always going to
explode this dynamic between the two of
them and it happened
this week okay let's just listen in for
a moment and hear what the two
protagonists have been saying just get a
flavor of what they the the
claims they've been making this past
week or so
with this the spirit of partnership in
the european union is retained
and a decisive step is taken to organize
and guide
secondary migration this is what has
been
and is important to me
this clear agreement which conforms to
my beliefs on
all three points allows me to continue
to carry out the office of federal
minister of the interior for building
and community
just picking up on what you were saying
matthew the this past week i mean i've
written down how the the coalition has
been characterized feuds backstabbing
rebellion
infighting animosity i could go on how
can they possibly work together in the
weeks to come where germany does face
really big challenges
well i wouldn't be surprised if sejova
leaves at some point in
the near future i don't think that the
coalition itself
will fall apart because they all have
too much at stake here and they all
fear new elections because they would
all suffer
if uh new elections were called so i do
i do think that the
the cdu miracles party and and say
hovers party the csu will
continue uh most likely without without
seijo for at some point
in the near future also because he
alienated a lot of people in his own
ranks on sunday
by you know announcing that he was
planning to resign which which really uh
caught caught a lot of people off guard
i think at the end of this episode the
details of this compromise i don't think
are
are that significant in the long term
it's very complicated i don't think that
you know merkel gave up that much to be
honest i mean this this story about
these transit zones that they're setting
up this is something that she first
proposed
in 2015. so it's an idea that that she
herself came up with
at the time it was it was not uh
possible because the social democrats at
the time said no they don't want to have
these camps on the border so
they they found this compromise it
sounds you know
very very dramatic to people but i think
at the end of the day what the what the
bavarians really wanted in this election
campaign that derek
uh spoke about is to be able to point to
their voters to these
camps that are going to be set up at the
border and say look we've established
these
refugee camps never mind that the
numbers there are actually uh quite
modest i think 1700
people actually applied for asylum on
the german austrian border last year
which is which is which is not a lot
um and nina matthew says that uh jor
sejofer alienated a lot of people by the
way he's been behaving this past week or
two
what's your name his own party as well
in his own party's mother was there was
you know there was bare fury in his
party uh
just a couple of days ago but also i
think an awful lot of women were
alienated from the way horse stahofer
has been behaving
uh you know you mentioned it matthew
talking about you know effectively i
made her chancellor and also saying
throwing his arms up in the air and
saying
i can't apparently saying he was
reported twice have said i can't work
with this woman
what did you make of all that as a woman
or as a citizen i think you know um
there were lots of people whether or not
they voted for merkel doesn't really
matter
who said you just can't talk to
a fellow politician like this this is
just no way of um of
dealing with this problem and it's it
just it was just so
transparent that this was a power
struggle and this was not like they're
trying to sell us now this was not about
the details
of a deal um that would have solved um
a problem that we have at the moment and
actually 69
of germans um share my view that this is
something where he should have
he should have resigned you know he
because he took it so far because he let
it
escalate and in view of what nina saying
derek
there's a word in german it's a
fascinating one of these big long german
words
political drastic disenchantment
disgruntlement disillusionment
with politics how much do you think that
has been stoked in the last couple of
weeks
and how much will that feed into growing
pole figures increasing pole figures for
the afd for the alternative for germany
i think so well i wouldn't worry too
much i mean summer is coming so i think
most people are on the beaches i don't
think they're watching the news and so
on so it's
pretty much just sort of wake me up when
this is over and is it over and did
anything change
and so on but i do think i do think we
have been witnessing something the last
few years and that's what i said my
introductory statement that sort of it's
like water is very slowly
under under uh unterspuden is the german
word it's like it's it's washing away
some of the foundations and i don't
think the stability disability we are
talking about here
i don't really believe it's as stable
i'm starting to see um
i've always said it i think it was
woodston churchill said in germany the
troubled germans during their
your ankles are at your throat and i
think what he was trying to say was
there's always this pendulum and there's
a repentance between self self suffrage
self satisfaction and self loathing and
we saw this week in the
german magazine de spiegel there once
was a stable country
which is utterly ridiculous i mean
they're talking about just because they
left the football and the cars are
you know cheating their customers and
car companies and now this political
crisis and
i do wonder that maybe people will over
over worry about what's actually going
on we're in a period of transition
in germany uh just like the rest of the
world i think germany has been cushioned
from a lot of what's been going on for
the last 10 years i mean germany didn't
have a real financial crisis
a period of transition from what to what
well i think this is this is the big
question
are we is germany going to become one of
the mainstream countries where you've
got this battle uh between you know
unilateralism multilateralism
is uh is it sort of germany first i mean
the bavarians that's what i think their
long-term game is they have
area first they've locked well bavaria
germany first and the leader down there
and some conservatives up here in berlin
are saying this miracle notion of
let's all be friends hold our hands and
come out with a compromise at three in
the mornings ridiculous we go in and we
bang on the table there are young men
in german politics who believe that now
and they i i think the long term what
we're seeing here is actually a cultural
clash between
does germany continue to moderate
politics where it tries to get as many
people on board and try to humiliate as
few people as possible
or do you go in and throw your weight
around and uh because they see
trump doing it they see other countries
doing it and they want a bit of the
action
i think that's the battle we're actually
seeing now and that's what worries me
slightly more
and that people whether people are
seeing that now i worry that people will
start reading newspapers that's
why germany is unstable germany's in
crisis it isn't
just because journalists think that i
don't really agree
matthew well i i agree i don't i don't
think that it's in crisis i
i think though it's it's worth noting
that one of the conclusions one could
make from the past couple of weeks is
that
uh this little rebellion that we saw
from the csu and
from some of the the young men as you
call them in in miracles party
uh really failed and i i i think there
is still a consensus in germany
a centrist consensus uh they they don't
want
to go to the unilateral approach as as
trump
uh has done and as uh the bavarians
appeared
to be pushing for uh they you know all
the polls suggest that the
germans remain committed to the eu they
remain committed to all of these
multilateral institutions the united
nations and so forth so
um if if this was an attempt to kind of
push germany in a different direction
it really failed and uh you know i think
what it what this whole uh
you know situation has shown to me is is
that
the this question of migration uh which
has dominated the
sort of political landscape for the last
couple of years remains unresolved
that's what this was about and this was
sort of
a symbol of that it was a manufactured
crisis yes but it was possible to
manufacture it because
miracle has still not resolved you know
this question
of uh migration and i think that this
was less about the the people who were
coming
than it is about the people who are
already here you know the one million
plus who have come over the past couple
of years
and the the sort of fears that many
germans have about that and that's what
the the afd taps into and i slightly
disagree with you on the other issues i
don't think that they have any other
issues
and if you look at other populist
parties around europe this is what they
have in common with the afd
is that you know they all kind of hue to
this to this question of migration and
what can be you know how they can use
that
to kind of instill fear in people
and when they've tried other issues such
as the euro the afd actually started as
an anti-hero party did pretty well for a
while and then
you know fell down into the low single
digits and it wasn't until 2015
with the refugee crisis that they shot
back up and that's where they've been
ever since so i think
until merkel somehow finds a solution
to the uh refugee question in in germany
um this is going to continue sorry but i
i think we have to talk about um
the fact that the when we talk about
migration we mean
refugees and migrants at the same time
still here in germany which is something
that
alienates a lot of people because when
we're talking about the writer asylum
this is something that
no german citizen questions you know
people who are
in need of protection they need to be
protected here
but what's happening at the moment is
that all of the problems that have
arisen
since we've had lots of people come here
um
and claim or apply for asylum here
simply because there are no other ways
into germany
there have been problems and we're not
dealing with them
in a separate way to the the asylum
issue itself so you know they are
beginning to talk about the need for an
immigration law
now at last you know after decades of
this actually being necessary
but what is happening is that there are
people who are saying okay we can't even
talk about the problems that we have
with new arrivals here because then
everybody will accuse us of
of being anti-immigrant or xenophobic
whatever but there are problems and we
just need to talk about
ways of integrating those who have a
right to stay here
and then of giving protection to people
who need to be protected but also
of keeping people out who just have no
way of of living here
picking up on what you're saying and
going back to matthew matthew you're
from politico your publication
your outlet says this week the
dehumanization of europe is on the march
and my my response to that was you know
is germany is the merkel government
actually
contributing now to the dehumanization
of europe
well i didn't write that and i actually
i actually disagree we've got a lot of
voices at
that point i don't think that she is
contributing to it i think you know this
is a fairly pragmatic approach and i
think a lot of people have
you know completely misread uh what
she's done here
i don't think this is a an about face at
all
um as i said she's the one who first
suggested this solution with
these uh transit zones number one and
number two if you look at what's
happened since 2015
uh with miracles government and the way
that it has uh
you know gradually tightened the asylum
rules
there have been two asylum packages as
they uh
call them the rules have become much
more stringent than they were
in 2015 she hasn't been out there you
know giving speeches about it hasn't
drawn a lot of attention to it
but it is today much more difficult as a
refugee
to uh get asylum in germany than it was
in 2015 so i think that
this is a another step that you know
at least superficially appears to um
you know tighten the rules a bit but in
substance it certainly
is not a major departure from her
previous policies and i don't think that
she's dehumanizing
europe at all i think that you know
there there is a practicality issue and
i think that you know this is what sort
of the mainstream german looks at this
situation and thinks well you know yes
we you know need to provide people
asylum we want to help but
there's sort of limits to what we can do
and this is sort of the the tension in
this debate and has been
uh from the beginning okay thank you for
those comments we'll bring you in
in just a moment derek because you were
talking earlier about whether
germany is entering a phase of malaise
or not you were rather skeptical about
that a lot of people here in germany not
just in the media
do believe that you know germany is
entering in malays
let's have a look back when the world
was still intact
september 2013 when germany's
conservative parties won an almost
absolute majority in the elections cdu
head angela mackel and her csu
counterpart jose hoffa were thrilled
now disenchantment has set in and not
only in politics
[Music]
the diesel scandal has devastated trust
in germany's manufacturing might
vw and audi but also mercedes and other
brands have been affected
new technologies were ignored by
management and instead emissions results
were falsified
deutsche bank's image has suffered too
bad loans three years of losses
it was the only bank to fail the us
stress test now it's counting on a
leadership change
[Music]
and what else oh yeah the germans can't
even play soccer anymore
the current reigning champion crashed
out of this year's world cup in the
group stage
with the worst showing in their group is
the team and its leadership too old too
satisfied
too self-aggrandizing germany in the
summer of 2018.
does the country have a problem with its
elites
go in there derek let's hear it does the
country have a problem is it mismanaged
in
soccer business politics is there a
crisis with the german illegal you lose
some i mean
you know when you win the world cup the
likelihood that you're going to win the
world cup or the eurovision song contest
the next time out is quite low
and yes they probably could have done
better but my god i mean the pressure
these people are on that they have to
deliver
every time you know i would say the car
the car
crisis was that's collusion between the
car industry and politics
they knew there was a problem uh the
politicians had put them under pressure
to deliver clean diesel which isn't
clearly
isn't possible and then they realized we
have to work on each other so i do think
there's a problem there
um but i've i've been here for almost 20
years and i've seen these sort of
cassandra journalists coming along
saying you know can germany be saved and
it always works well in talk shows
because the person who says well maybe
it'll be okay
seems hopelessly naive but what i have
learned in 20 years in germany is that
germans don't react at the first alarm
bell and they don't react at the second
alarm bell but somewhere between the
second and the third and final alarm
bell somebody goes oh jesus we have to
do something
and something happens i don't know if
it's merkel who's the person who will
be react she's known for being able to
jump off the diving board
in her swimming lesson or act in
politics just at the last moment
i'm starting to wonder if you know she's
just like lots of people she's had a lot
a long crisis field run and she's done
some extra extraordinary things
in europe in terms of stability but
maybe she needs to move whether she
realizes that herself
but this notion that germany itself is
oh you know one swallow doesn't make a
summer and three disasters doesn't make
you know
a catastrophe you know it's it's not the
apocalypse um
but you know it's always very
fashionable to say germany's in crisis
and to add up all these things and their
spiegel did it this week and
stirred it furiously and lots of people
swallow it and say oh yes it must be
true
you know a plus b plus c equals zed yeah
whatever
you know sorry
no i i agree um that there is a risk
that you
overestimate the effects of football in
germany
um but at the same time i would say that
lots of people here in germany and
probably an increasing amount of people
feel disenfranchised they feel
like the politicians are no longer
dealing with the real issues you know
we've
we've established that there are no big
amounts of migrants coming into germany
at the moment
exactly because they don't even have to
deliver a solution
because everybody else all the other
parties are involved in their own
meddlings the social democrats it would
be a perfect opportunity for them
to now say okay this is our stance on
migration this is what we want for the
future
this is how we're going to solve your
problems when it comes um
to care for the elderly this is um what
we're going to do for families etc
they're not delivering
so all the afd have to do is say we've
got a problem
with and i disagree with you that
migration is the only
problem the only issue that they have
you know because they don't
have solutions they just need to name
the problems that people have
well i i would just yeah say i think
it's i think it's the issue that that
resonates most
in in germany and and in other countries
i mean one of the things that's
interested me about the german
discussion is that
the germans are sort of discovering
slowly what it means to have a
successful
populist party a successful far-right
party and everybody's like really
shocked you know
if you look around the rest of europe
this has been going on for for quite
some time and
there was an afd politician last week
when when germany lost who posted
on facebook or twitter a picture of
maison uzi
the uh the german player uh who has
turkish roots and there was a bit of a
controversy involving
uh some photographs that he had taken
together with erdogan before
before the world cup and uh this afd
politician essentially blamed ozil for
this and said you know
suggested he should be sent back to
turkey and a lot of people were very
upset about that but this is kind of
thing
that has been going on in france it's
been going on in austria the netherlands
you know for
for many years so i think that you know
if anything the political landscape here
is sort of catching
catching up a bit to uh to to to the
rest of europe
uh but you know coming back to what what
derek said about you know is this
you know the end of german stability um
you know i i think it's definitely
becoming becoming less stable and while
it's it's not a catastrophe i do think
that there are signs
in the economy in particular that this
kind of second
economic miracle that germany's been
going through over the past
few years is coming to an end let's give
them and we've got about a minute to go
derek
and i want to hear what you have to say
about all of that because you at the
beginning of the show
said germany has a stability obsession
you implied that that should become a
thing of the past that they should shake
the obsession off
and you suggested that that would lead
to fresh air fresh thinking fresh
partners
that intrigued me tell me more um i
think angela merkel is a bit like
have you ever heard of lawn mower
parenting this is where a parent moves
ahead of the child and clears all
obstacles out of the way
germans for the last 10 or 15 years
haven't had to worry about politics they
haven't had to worry about what's going
on in the world
merkel was the moot of everything called
i'll tell you when you need to wake up
well it's time to wake up and i think
people are starting to realize that
it's time to really engage with politics
again and that can only be a good thing
because having a surrogate who agrees to
do everything for you that's like a very
very soft dictatorship
and i don't think that's good for any
democracy and not for germany okay thank
you very much for those comments i
really would like to have heard more but
it's been great stuff fascinating i hope
we've given you at home some food for
thought quadriga this week german
stability
a thing of the past if you've enjoyed
the show come back next week bye bye
cheers
[Music]
you